[Music]
to that breaking news and another
escalation intention between Israelis
and Palestinians to Israeli settlers
have been killed another seriously
injured in a shooting in the northeast
of the occupied West Bank this happened
in Alhambra in the Jordan Valley region
rasul sirdar is an occupied East
Jerusalem rasul what happened what can
you tell us at this stage
well so far what we know is from the
Israeli sources according to the Israeli
authorities three Israeli women the
settlers were shot in the Jordan Valley
area and one of the driver the lady that
was attacked she lost the control of the
car and hit another man so this this is
a shooting attack according to the
Israeli authorities or two women or that
and one is critically injured for now so
initially the Israeli authorities were
assassin this as a as a traffic accident
however later they said that this is an
attack conducted by an attacker the the
identity of the attacker is not clear
yet but we know that the Israeli
security forces have blocked the area
and now they started the manhound their
contact conducting a Manhunt to find the
attacker and also there are the reports
that after losing the control of the car
the driver has run over another a man so
that's also injured but as of now we
know that two women are dead and the
attacker is being searched by the
Israeli Security Forces so it is
becoming tense again so the initial
reports today or the statements from the
Israeli sides were showing the sign of
de-escalation however this attack and
also right behind me you can see that
people are preparing for the Friday
prayer so thousands of people are
already Gathering here this
a compound was the source of the tension
that started on Wednesday now thousands
of people are gathering there and
getting ready to conduct their Friday
prayer and that also could escalate
another tension here because the
Palestinians here are saying that if the
Israeli Security Forces decide to arrest
people here or attack to the players
again then this could lead to a wider
conflict again so the situation is quite
fragile quite tense here however the
general expectation in the morning was
that the Israeli authorities and the
Palestinian fractions are going to
de-escalate but as I said this recent
attack and now the the the the behavior
or the the approach of the Israeli
Security Forces after the player are
going to show us what today is going to
look like all right rasul you're going
to keep a surprise the developments and
what's going on exactly where you are
all of this coming after this lethal
violence coming after violence in the
Alexa mosque compound Islam's third
holiest site
[Applause]
Israeli forces used batons on
Palestinian worshipers arriving for
morning prayers on Friday and soon after
hundreds of people gathered in the
compound to protest against Israel's
actions
we are joined by Mustafa barguti he
you're the Secretary General of the
Palestinian national initiative you join
us from Ramallah you heard what rasul
sirdar was reporting on a lethal
shooting attack
near alhamra your reaction to that sir
it's one of the side effects or the
results of what the Israeli Army did in
Alaska mosque they have provoked the
feelings of all Palestinians and all
Arabs and all Muslims and today they are
even making more restrictions not only
for Muslims but also for Christians who
are trying to celebrate the the
we just lost the audio there we will go
back to Mr burguti as soon as we can I
believe we are able to reconnect
Mr burguti can you hear me hello
yes yes I can hear you okay we lost your
audio there for a second
um you were interrupted mid answer carry
on please sir
okay what I was saying that is what we
see today is the result of the Israeli
Army Behavior inside the AXA mosque the
brutally beat people they arrested 400
people while they were worshiping uh if
this has happened inside the most inside
the synagogue what would have been the
world reaction they have provoked the
feelings of all Palestinians Muslims and
Arabs but they also are provoking the
feelings of Christians today when they
are trying to prevent them from
celebrating Easter in Jerusalem if they
were Palestinians this is a situation
that is a result of a long-term
occupation the longest in modern history
and a system of discriminatory apartheid
and racism
for a second are you suggesting that
killing settlers is an appropriate
response
no I'm not saying I am not an advocate
of violence you know me well but I am
saying that violence is a symptom of the
disease and the disease has been the
long occupation of Palestinian land the
disease has been the system of apartheid
and oppression
and the fact that the Israeli people
have chosen a government that has
fascists in it like being Veer and
smotherich these guys are saying bluntly
that they are fascists they are saying
that the Palestinians have to live or
die or accept a life of subjugation to
the to the Israeli oppression this is
the cause of the problem and let me
remind you that the Israeli Army killed
96 Palestinians since the beginning of
this year including 17 children and one
old woman this is the what we see today
is a reaction a reaction to the Israeli
government Behavior so the last three
days have seen tensions Spike over who
can access Alexa mosque when and for how
long is there a fix to this and I mean
this immediate problem
there is a no fix if unless Israel
allows us to reach the city of Jerusalem
we don't want to visit Israel we want to
be in East Jerusalem which is occupied
it's part of the occupied West Bank
but they are not allowing more than 95
percent of the Palestinians to reach
there only people who live in Jerusalem
or people who live inside Israel can go
there but the rest of us are prevented I
lived I lived for 15 years in Jerusalem
working as a medical doctor I I was born
in East Jerusalem and I am prevented
from reaching Jerusalem since 2005. if I
want to go I try to get to the AXA
mosque two weeks ago they told me to go
back like most people
and then if I if I wanted to go I have
to sneak in this is the only way the
reality is that the vast majority of
Palestinian Muslims and Christians are
not allowed to reach the holy places are
not allowed to worship peacefully inside
Jerusalem and the AXA mosque or holy
saprical church that is the reality and
even when they say that they allow
people above the age of 65 to cross many
are turned back claiming that they
represent a security threat so at this
moment in time in light of the clashes
that we've seen this week at Alexa
mosque in light also of this latest
development the killing of two Jewish
settlers what is your message to
Israelis on the one hand and
Palestinians on the other
my message is that the road to peace is
easy and simple
it starts with ending the illegal
Israeli occupation of Palestinian land
it starts with accepting us as equal
human beings it starts with an Israeli
decision to eliminate the system of
apartheid and oppression of the
Palestinian people
no Colonial system has everlasted and if
some Israelis think that Palestinians
will accept a life of subjugation to
their oppression and enslavement in a
system of apartheid they are wrong and
mistaken the road to peace is simple
they should end occupation and
settlement activities and the system of
apartheid allow Palestinian refugees to
come back home to the land that have
been deprived from reaching for so many
years and then we can have peace nothing
from what we say is against Israeli or
Jewish people as people but we are
struggling against occupation against
apartheid against fascists like
smotherich and being weird who are also
trying to destroy even the Israelis
dictionary system and I think many
Israelis now realize that these fascists
who are in the government now in Israel
are the result of this long-term
occupation and a system of apartheid
that produced eventually fascism in
Israel
yeah Mustafa baruti Secretary General of
the Palestinian national initiative
thank you for joining us on the program
thank you so much
now the attack in the occupied West Bank
comes after a series of airstrikes
carried out by the Israeli military in
Gaza Israel's military says it hits
sites belonging to Hamas that's after
its Iron Dome defense system intercepted
several Rockets fired from the strip
well let's go to Gaza now yumna assayed
is standing by bring us up to speed on
what happened overnight in the early
morning hours
yes so since last night Israeli
warplanes pounded the Gaza Strip in
different areas at the same time
bombarding more than 10 targets and
almost all the evacuated military camps
belonging to Hamas in addition to
agriculture lands no casualties were
reported the Ministry of Health did say
that Dura Children Hospital was
partially damaged due to the intense
targeting around the area of where the
hospital is also a residential home was
severely damaged because of the
targeting of Agriculture lands next to
that home barriers of rockets were
launched from the Gaza Strip towards
Israeli towns and anti-aircrafts were
also fired on the Israeli drones and
crafts
all right yum that assayed reporting
from Gaza thank you very much
and Israel has also launched airstrikes
into parts of Southern Lebanon and
claims to have hit also hit Hamas
targets there the military says its
retaliation for Rockets fired into
Israel on Thursday while local Witnesses
say the missiles hit an open area near a
Palestinian refugee camp
zaina zainauder is in southern Lebanon
entire show us the scene where you are
and what you've seen
well yes we are at one of the sites that
was targeted by Israeli Plains overnight
approximately four in the morning we are
not allowed to you know move any further
because the Lebanese Army is now
investigating uh the area there's a big
crater here and it's an open field it's
one of like I mentioned four targets now
the Israeli Army said it targeted
positions belonging to the Palestinian
group Hamas in a Southern Lebanon Israel
is blaming the Palestinian group for
launching the barrage of rockets into
Northern Israel late on Thursday even
though there has been no claim of
responsibility it was a serious
escalation one of the most serious
escalations along the border since the
2006 war between Israel and Hezbollah
but it's clear Israel's response was
limited and measured and according to
the United Nations peacekeeping Force
they have been in contact with the
different parties on the ground neither
Lebanon nor Israel wants War so tensions
have been diffused this round of
hostilities is over but this is clearly
a political message and that message is
if Israel continues to launch attacks
against Palestinians attack worshipers
then
Palestinian groups have supporters
across the region the so-called axis of
resistance who will open other fronts
zaina unsurprisingly the Lebanese
government not best pleased that its
territory has been targeted by Israel
the foreign Ministry is now saying that
it's going to file a complaint with the
U.N security Council tell us more about
that
yes usually the Lebanese foreign
Ministry files complaints at the U.N
security Council whenever there's an
Israeli airstrike or if Israeli planes
violate Lebanese airspace more often
than not nothing nothing changes and and
nothing happens as you can see behind me
the U.N peacekeepers have now also
arrived at the scene to carry out
investigations because the Lebanese Army
as well as the United Nations have still
not pointed the blame at at any party
yes the Lebanese government is concerned
it doesn't want an escalation the
Lebanese government is hoping that
tensions will be refused this is a
cash-strapped state nearly bankrupt it
cannot afford another War but neither
can Hezbollah yes security sources say
that Palestinian groups are most likely
behind this operation the launching of
rockets yesterday but they wouldn't have
done it without the support and approval
of Hezbollah and Hezbollah too doesn't
want any Adventures that this this point
in time because of course it will it
will it will be blamed many people here
cannot afford to put food on the table
and that's why many analysts believe
that the best card to use right now when
sending a political message is through
the Palestinians
reporting from Southern Lebanon thank
you very much